Oh God two is missing now we're we're
rude always there oh hey ulcer how are
you doing going out for a midnight snack
well this is the restroom you [ __ ] to
[ __ ] go to the right restaurant idiot
you have beautiful eyes also but
seriously no midnight selfies please
Oh God where is she Oh for the love of
dicks are they moving they're not moving
so far what is missing 1s missing where
hey hey there little fella
how you doing there chap Oh God
where did he go Jeff bloody feet dance
ballet wait [ __ ] you [ __ ] off whoa whoa
what the [ __ ] is I what the [ __ ] are you
is it more than no oh god no oh god no
they're all gone oh that is some creepy
[ __ ] man you cannot come in and eat here
no you can't you [ __ ] go home you're
drunk stop go home oh oh oh oh oh that's
great
I want to go home now I'm pretty sure
that whatever they paying me here is not
worth it Oh Jason